[Música]
[Aplausos]
votar não sei o que viram
quando fui à igreja já era tarde demais
espero que não tenha tirado fotografias
porque já sabem tudo falso tudo aquilo
virou dúvida nesta manhã
bom eu sou eu sou músico isso é verdade
e escolhi a música música clássica
nomeadamente por uma razão muito simples
e muito fácil de explicar que é coisa
que mais gosta de fazer e portanto na
altura de escolher música eu não
perguntei a ninguém mas era difícil jô
desafios a que estaria foi uma escolha
quase conquistar hedonista que eu decidi
fazer aquilo que verdadeiramente gostam
quando for pra frente com música e agora
estamos a chegar a este mês de verão as
temporadas sinfônicas de concertos
acabam e vão começar as vendas de
bilhetes para a próxima temporada que
arranca em setembro eu já sei que isso
vai acontecer mas desafios desafio é ver
o lançamento de uma temporada mas não é
verdade que o diretor ou diretora ou a
pessoa que dá a cara por esta temporada
vai explicar porque temos que comprar
bilhetes para ver concertos nesta
temporada porque é imprevisível e
artistas extraordinários concertos
memoráveis momentos incríveis que vão
mudar a nossa vida melhor e eu ou este
discurso pessoal estivesse marketing e
marketing música muda a vida de alguém
alguma vez na vida
bom mas o discurso é de facto tão
insistente que eu começo a pensar bem
então isso cria uma profissão que não dá
muito prazer comenta traz benefícios
para as pessoas sem outra fazer nada por
isso eu achava que as profissões que
facto lutam por melhorias no mundo dão
muito trabalho são difíceis exigem
sacrifícios e música pra mim é mesmo só
prazer portanto se isso traz melhorias
imaginava que essas profissões a ser
médico ser bombeiro enfim essas coisas
aqui faz traziam uma melhoria na
qualidade de vida das pessoas e ao
momento em que eu vejo iniciativa um
projeto piloto a ser conduzido no
hospital que é o lugar por influência
para melhorar
a vida das pessoas que quiseram nem
hospital foi até ele se move instalou há
um projeto de arte tantas pessoas tenham
contato com a arte isso melhorar a
qualidade de vida delas no hospital eu
fiquei pensando como então vamos parar
para melhorar a qualidade de vida no
cálculo influência é o sítio onde as
pessoas vão para melhorar a sua
qualidade de vida e achei isso muito
interessante então se calhar nós podemos
mesmo fazer uma coisa boa vida das
pessoas e aos é tem peso a esta pergunta
às pessoas que lá estavam e depois
montou um projeto online que apresentava
este piloto e perguntaram de 50
se a arte pode mudar a sociedade e eu
sou músico mas gostaram falar de arte
porque tal como um um ecossistema de
biodiversidade também as artes são todas
irmãs dependem umas das outras e
contamina mãos e polinizam se umas às
outras portanto quando eu disser música
é um pintura literatura o que importa
não possa articular a sociedade para
melhor em tendas estarão questionário e
as pessoas podiam votar e os resultados
são reveladores de confiança que as
pessoas têm de que a opel fax mudar pra
sociedade para melhor pode ser argentino
lança as pessoas que estão convencidos
disto são muito mais do que todas as
outras franjas de opinião estão
resultados fortíssimos que não deixou
espaço para questões e eu então é certo
que de facto a arte pode mudar a nossa
vida e começa a pensar nisso então vou
descobrir de que forma é que enquanto
artista possa ter um papel na sociedade
a primeira conclusão a que chego é muito
simples é parar de mudar a vida de
alguém ela tem que fazer parte dessa
vida
esta é uma lei muito simples e será que
a arte é parte de nossa vida e eu começo
a pensar que tipo de relação é que as
pessoas têm com as várias formas de a
todos nós temos pinturas em casa pelos
livros ouvimos música qual é a nossa
forma de consumo e artístico e que o que
eu vejo muitas vezes é uma atitude
desolação quarto de fruição e é qualquer
coisa assim deste gênero que se acredita
que é mau o o o tem uma característica
que é uma espécie de analgésico é esta
pessoa está ouvindo
se querem uma atitude de reclusão não
podemos imaginar que este é o dia livre
que não têm trabalho então só que chega
tarde em casa cansada tira o casaco e
gravata e vai ouvir aquela música esta é
uma atitude na verdade de escape da sua
vida seja a pessoa está a usar a arte
como quem chega a casa e matou
comprimido de dissolver na água e tomar
quilo e enxaqueca passa isso não tem
nada de mal a arte pode ser um
analgésico e nesse sentido pode trazer
enormes melhorias para a nossa vida
média depois começa a ver as várias
formas de artes várias obras de arte que
nós conseguiremos nossos museus é que
nós ficamos
acho que muita dela muitos desses corpo
de arte não tem esta função de
analgésico que é às vezes o encontro com
leveza portuguesa pode sim ser
apaziguador e pode nos libertar das
misérias do nosso dia a dia mas há
muitas obras tatu que manifestamente não
são analgésicos
como é que nós podemos isto por exemplo
toda a gente conhece esta pintura até
porque é um molde ano nosso teclado é
uma pintura que significa não acredito
mas quando o monte então esta pintura
ela não queria dizer isso esta pintura
era exagero de expressão e não fazia
ninguém sentir se bem nem era um
encontro com a beleza então como é que
se justifica esta pintura que não
estávamos eu estou pagam bilhete prever
uma coisa que não nos proporciona este
efeito analgésico que quer tem mais em
tão bom aqui tem muita coisa mas para
chegarmos temos que perceber que há uma
bifurcação das formas de fruição da arte
há uma que eu chame passiva e é da
pessoa que procura apenas este
relaxamento este efeito analgésico na
área e deixa que arte é conduzido para
fora da sua vida de uma forma ativa e
formativa e nova aquela que eu vou
querer que todos tenham um é é uma forma
de nos concessionários quarto que
pressupõe que a arte é transportadora de
uma mensagem qualquer forma de artistas
da música seja a pintura é uma linguagem
tem o seu próprio significado notificado
através de sons ou através de imagens ou
através de texto e quando imaginamos
nesta fruição ativa
então eu vou ao diretor da nossa sala de
concertos que não está a vender os
bilhetes da temporada e pergunta se eu
for perguntar né
o que é um sucesso na temporada essa
pessoa vai dizer é ter a sala cheia em
todos os concertos dos bilhetes todos
vendidos
eu pergunto mas quantas pessoas neste
concerto que espera uma forma da sida
quantas as que estão lá de forma ativa
porque nós como a que estamos a dar
seguimento às pessoas é que as pessoas
as regras não elas não crescem e esta
esta questão da forma ativa passiva pois
vou pensar também pelo também está em
quadro na minha sala onde trabalham em
um quadro
todos os dias passo por eu ea única
coisa que eu penso é também um espaço
branco na parede onde um dia que estava
ter um outro quadro acho que compor a
sala e ficar mais bonita e fazia sentido
que você pensar porque eu preciso ter
aqui um outro quadro quando nem sequer
estou a prestar atenção estes já têm
mensagens aquela batata
então todos os dias o desafio é o sítio
está no meu computador e também o piano
e olhavam que tenho por esse quadro e
todos os dias eu descobrir qualquer
coisa diferente
portanto eu entrei numa relação de
interpretação com aquela obra data e é
só para andar pelas ruas sem grande
surpresa infinita força infinita no
sentindo cada dia que eu voltava a
relacionado com ela eu encontrava
qualquer coisa que esta obra de arte foi
pra mim foi literalmente esse jogador de
cimento eu gostava que a área fosse para
todos e em vez de ser um ponto de fuga
para a minha realidade passou a ser um
ponto de encontro em que eu me encontro
com essa obra aqui não funciona com ela
em vez de ser um exercício de abstração
o conforto passa a ser um exercício de
concentração em vez de ser uma sensação
de alívio
essa minha relação óbvia a data passa a
ser uma emoção desafio em que estou
sendo estimulado para procurar
significados e portanto sequer a obra da
artista infinita isso nós também somos
infinitos na nossa humanidade nas nossas
prioridades
quer dizer que cada vez que nós nos
cruzamos como obra de arte ela vai gerar
reações reações variáveis diferentes e
que são notáveis seu próprio mundo das
minhas reações que acontece quando todos
temos reações e começamos a confrontar
as nossas reações
é que acha daqui um debate no sentido
positivo uma troca de conhecimentos e
experiências de idéias e que leva um
debate leva inevitavelmente uma evolução
a uma construção coletiva do
conhecimento das conclusões a que nós
chegamos e o que significa significa que
estamos a construir uma comida e isso é
uma obra de arte pode fazer pausa na
verdade ajudar a construir uma obra de
arte
e portanto eu não estou por uma
sociedade se relaciona com arte creche
ea partir dela o que é naturalmente
manifesta o pedro que conecta vamos
imaginar as pessoas a virem um concerto
em que houve uma sinfonia de mozart
trocarem impressões e irem para casa
impressionar e nem se discute o que
ouviram e no dia seguinte voltar e ouvir
coisas novas e tomar decisões a partir
disso é uma coisa que nunca se ouviu
falar e você também daí o tópico mas na
verdade não é nossa sociedade
democrática
nós convivemos temos a função de
defender nós sabemos em atenas onde a
cidadania era convocada não é
dispersasse que não para seu sítio no
seu contacto quarta vamos encontrar se
um verdadeiro fórum era o teatro é um
espaço em que todos os cidadãos eram
convidados em encontrar se encontrasse
conforme as datas que não eram o
analgésico não eram este encontro olesa
vai fazer sentir bem
nós sabemos que qualquer tragédia grega
um édipo ray o antigo é um electra nós
vamos ver coisas horríveis nos ver em
sexto no recírio vamos ver todas as
misérias possíveis e isso servia para
ensinar e educar a sociedade os
atenienses para que eu sei sem do teatro
a pensar nas coisas que acabaram de ver
e para se porem no lugar do édipo e para
imaginarem o que eles fariam se tivessem
naquelas situações e esta experiência
era a construção era assim
entre outras formas que se construía a
sociedade 504 ea democracia está no
campo da política não está
necessariamente no campo da arte tanto
que eu estou a tentar dizer com isto é
carente possa fazer certas coisas que
competem a política é muito simples
porque a arte não pertence sempre a
realidade ea política está enquadrada na
realidade é política não pode dissociar
das pessoas
além das vidas nem situações reais e
realistas ato pode e com isso pode levar
anos para lugares que nós não teríamos
imaginado conceber e vai na cabeça uma
uma citação do lãder br 101 é mestre
brigador que muito admiro falava das
sinfonias de uma aula são um conjunto
sem influir descritas por um homem
profundamente atormentado e essas
influências são espécies de um depósito
de todas as experiências que o ser
humano pode ter desde pior das misérias
ele é um homem que conheceu miséria
pessoal e humana até o mais alto
esfuziante dos artistas e opera sempre
perguntava qual é o sentido deste
conjunto sinfonias grotesco e disforme
entanto consegue ser sublime quando
consegue ser coisa mais miserável
possível localizar é este conjunto
sinfonias é na verdade o purgatório o
mala escreve esta sinfonia para que nós
passemos os pacientes sem na verdade ter
que passar por elas e para nos
enriquecer e é dessa forma e sinfonias
podem enriquecer o mundo nós podemos sim
ter este encontro apaziguador portuguesa
e não há mal nenhum nisso mas parte
verdadeiramente construir uma sociedade
e é isso que eu descobri posso fazer
caminhada
nós temos que conseguir plantar essa
semente mas também escala e ficava
acabamos nós todos não apenas novos
músicos e pintores que temos a função de
servir a nossa língua mas também as
pessoas também quem vai ver lá quem se
vai encontrar com ela tem que perceber
tem que se lembrar que estava em uma
linguagem viva a chegada de significado
e é por isso que eu acho que faz ouvir
não chega onde e chega ainda menos para
melhorar o mundo da arte tal como muitas
outras coisas certas para nos acordar
serve para nos dar aquela não nós
precisamos para que nós pensamos em
coisas gravíssimas sem na verdade temos
que passar por elas
por isso não basta o vídeo é preciso
ouvir o que os outros ouvem e é preciso
ouvir o que há de nos desfazer alvo com
isso muito obrigado a experimentar
[Aplausos]